Game of Thrones Season 8 Episode 2 is called
A Knight of the Seven Kingdoms.
It’s the calm before the storm at Winterfell,
with characters celebrating life – before
the dead arrive.
Jaime Lannister wants to help fight the white
walkers.
But Daenerys and Sansa don’t trust him,
because he’s the brother of their enemy,
Cersei.
Sansa’s mad because Jaime fought against
her family . And Daenerys is mad cause Jaime
killed her father , the Mad King, twenty years
ago.
Jaime killed the king to save a city from
wildfire . But when Ned Stark found him at
the Throne, he judged Jaime guilty , and ever
after, Jaime was hated as a Kingslayer, and
oathbreaker . And now, Jaime’s judged again,
by Ned Stark’s daughter, and the Mad King’s
daughter – his past is coming back to haunt
him.
But this time, there’s someone who believes
in Jaime.
Brienne says Jaime is an honourable man, that
he protected her, and kept his oaths.
Brienne shows Jaime trust and respect like
no one ever has.
So Jaime gets his sword back – Widow’s
Wail, one of the two Valyrian swords that
were melted down from Ned Stark’s old sword,
Ice.
The other sword, Oathkeeper, is used by Brienne.
So in Jaime and Brienne, Ned’s sword is
symbolically reforged – his steel is protecting
House Stark once more – in the hand of the
man who he’d once judged guilty.
Jaime reveals that Cersei lied – she’s
not gonna help the good guys, she’s just
wants to hold the Throne . Which means Tyrion
was wrong again – his whole plan of the
wight hunt and the peace summit was for Cersei’s
cooperation.
Turns out that was all for nothing.
Tyrion has failed Daenerys over and over , so
she threatens to replace him as Hand . If
Tyrion can’t find purpose and self-worth
serving Daenerys, what will he do?
Jaime apologises to Bran, the boy he crippled
in Episode 1 . Bran didn’t tell anyone that
Jaime pushed him, cause if he did, the Starks
wouldn’t have let Jaime join them.
Bran takes the philosophical view that if
Jaime hadn’t crippled him, Bran wouldn’t
have become the magic three-eyed raven, and
Jaime wouldn’t have become a heroic man.
But Bran also makes an ominous comment that
there might not be an “afterwards” for
Jaime . You get the sense the Bran knows the
future – and he has had some visions of
the future before . But we don’t know the
full extent of his powers since he became
the raven.
He says he can see “Everything that's ever
happened, to everyone” and “Everything
that's happening right now” – but the
visions are confused and fragmented . So in
practice, he’ll probably just know whatever’s
convenient to the plot at the time.
Gendry works as a blacksmith, and Arya enjoys
the view – just like she did in Season 2.
Gendry remembers Arya as this plucky young
girl, but Arya shows him she’s something
else now – closer to John Wick than Arry
the orphan boy . She talks about death , and
throws daggers, and Gendry’s impressed,
confused, and aroused.
Later, Gendry brings the weapon Arya ordered
– a sort of staff, with dragonglass at both
ends.
It’s like the weapon of Symeon Star-Eyes,
a legendary knight mentioned in the books.
He had a double-ended staff , and he was blind
– just like Arya was blind.
But there are also hints that Symeon was some
kind of white walker – he went to the Nightfort,
and had “star sapphires” in his eyes , like
a walker’s eyes . In the last scene, Arya
asks Gendry how many wights he’s fought
. Now, she asks how many girls he’s had
sex with . Last scene was about death, this
scene’s about life.
Arya doesn’t want to die a virgin – so
she and Gendry have sex.
Arya has suffered so much death and darkness
– now she finally gets some love and light.
But afterwards, Arya looks alone, while Podrick
sings of sorrow and pain.
Arya had once asked Gendry to be her family
. But after everything she’s been through,
Arya can’t reconnect.
In the books, she says there’s a hole inside
her where her heart had been, that it will
“never feel any better” . A lot of people
were shocked to see Arya have sex, but no
one seemed to mind when she committed mass
murder – because our culture and morals
are completely fucked.
Jaime and Brienne make awkward small talk
about the left flank and the rise on the ground
until Brienne snaps, and basically asks what
is their relationship now?
They used to hate each other, then they saved
each other, and now they’re starting to
love each other, and Brienne doesn’t know
how to handle that.
Remember, when Brienne was young, some boys
pretended to like her.
But it turned out to be a cruel joke – they
mocked her as “Brienne the Beauty”.
So it makes sense that Brienne is suspicious
when a man shows her affection and respect
– especially when Jaime was always so horrible
to her . So Jaime does something he’s never
done before.
He humbly and sincerely submits himself to
Brienne, says he’s not a great fighter any
more, but he’d “be honored to serve”
her . Jaime rejects the pride and cruelty
that once defined him, and he honours the
woman who showed him how to be a better man.
Also, we learn that Podrick is a badass now.
Remember what a goober he was in Season 2?
This is the best character transformation
since Lancel Lannister.
Jorah tells Daenerys that she should forgive
Tyrion’s mistakes.
Jorah had wanted to be Daenerys’ Hand himself,
but he says that Tyrion is the right man for
the job.
Jorah used to be jealous and controlling with
Daenerys.
He undermined her other advisors, cause he
wanted her all to himself . Now, he’s grown
past that, and does whatever’s truly best
for Daenerys – he even accepts that Daenerys
loves Jon not him . Jorah’s become a better
man, his arc seems complete – which probably
means he’ll die next episode.
Jorah also advises Dany to make peace with
Sansa.
So Daenerys finds some common ground with
Sansa – they’re both powerful women with
“complicated” families . But Sansa is
suspicious that Dany is manipulating Jon – exploiting
his love for her political gain.
Sansa knows that her brother Robb’s love
for Talisa led to his downfall . But Daenerys
argues that, if anything, Jon has manipulated
her.
Daenerys came to Westeros to take the Iron
Throne, but Jon convinced her to come north
and fight walkers instead – Daenerys delayed
her life’s ambition partly out of love for
Jon.
But Sansa asks what happens after the walkers
are defeated – cause Daenerys still wants
to rule Westeros, including the north.
Sansa’s family fought and died to rule the
north themselves – Robb battled the Lannisters,
Sansa and Jon battled the Boltons, and Sansa
doesn’t want all that to be for nothing.
She wants an independent north , and Daenerys
doesn’t want to give to her.
She probably just should, though – she promised
the Greyjoys an independent Iron Islands , why
not an independent north?
This conflict feels kind of contrived.
But the point is that Dany and Sansa understand
each other better now, but there’s still
tension.
Theon Greyjoy arrives, and says he’ll fight
for the Starks . He wants to redeem himself
for betraying the Starks in Season 2.
He and Sansa have an emotional hug.
They survived Ramsay together – no one else
really understands what they went through.
Sansa and Theon grew up like siblings at Winterfell,
and now they’re finally back home, together.
Davos feeds the common folk.
You’ve gotta feel sorry for these random
peasants who’ve been conscripted to fight
in World War Z.
Most of the real soldiers died in Robb’s
war, or the Battle of the Bastards.
These hapless leftovers will be slaughtered
by the walkers.
Gilly is also helping the commons.
She started out so meek and afraid – now
she’s a confident and compassionate leader.
She and Davos meet a girl called Teela, who’s
looks like Shireen – the girl who taught
Davos and Gilly how to read.
Teela has a burn on her face, which looks
like Shireen’s greyscale – it’s also
a reminder that Shireen was burned.
These are the sorts of people who will die
by the thousands when the walkers come – it’s
always the innocents who suffer most . Gilly
tells Teela to stay in the crypt during the
battle, because the crypt is safe.
Five times this episode, we’re told that
the crypt is “safe” , which practically
guarantees that something awful will happen
there.
The crypt is full of dead Starks, and the
white walkers can raise the dead, so maybe
recently dead Starks like Rickon will attack
– there are lots of hints in the books of
dead Starks rising . But most of the dead
in the crypt are very old, there wouldn’t
be bodies left.
We have seen some spooky skeleton wights in
the past, but most of the dead Starks are
dust.
So maybe there’s some other icy danger down
there.
The books mention deeper, darker, ancient
levels to the crypt , which might hold some
terrible secret, like a captive Night’s
Queen or something.
Or maybe there’s a secret entrance, so the
walkers could attack from within.
Or maybe there’s protective magic and the
crypts really are safe.
Tormund Beric and Edd come to Winterfell,
and Jon gets a bear-hug from Tormund.
They’ve had a crazy relationship.
Jon once climbed the Wall with Tormund’s
wildings, then betrayed him, and fought against
him at the battle for Castle Black.
Then, they fought together – at Hardhome,
Winterfell, and beyond the Wall.
This wildling leader and Night’s Watchman
have become allies and friends.
Tormund says the dead are coming, and everyone
one not at Winterfell is with them . The walkers
have taken Last Hearth, and are almost at
Winterfell – so they could also have Karhold,
and the Dreadfort, and many little villages,
as well as all the wildling land.
The army of the dead will be huge – and
Tormund says they’ll arrive tomorrow . So
Winterfell has new defences.
The opening sequence shows trenches round
the castle, and the plan is to light them,
as a barrier of fire . Fire does stop wights
– the zombies – but it doesn’t stop
white walkers, the ice creatures.
The walkers are vulnerable to dragonglass,
so there’s dragonglass on the walls, and
on caltrops, and there’s heaps of dragonglass
weapons.
There’ve also got trebuchets, and traps.
But the army of the dead is too big, the wights
don’t sleep or stop , and every human who’s
killed can be raised again as a wight.
So everyone gets together and makes a plan.
The walkers are led by the Night King, and
Jon hopes that if the Night King dies, all
the walkers and wights will die too . And
Bran says the Night King will come for him
. Bran was marked by the Night King in Season
6, it’s like a GPS tracker so he always
knows where Bran is.
So they plan to use Bran as bait – putting
him in the godswood to lure the Night King.
Theon and the ironborn will guard Bran , which
is cool cause there was foreshadowing in Season
1 that Theon would battle in the godswood
. This seems like the perfect setup for Theon
to heroically sacrifice himself.
Jon says they’ll keep the dragons nearby,
to protect Bran and wait for the Night King
– but they won’t use the dragons in the
field . Which seems really dumb.
Dragons breathe fire – they’re not good
at protecting wheelchair-bound wizards in
flammable forests – they’re really good
at burning zombies.
Surely the dragons are the only real hope
of stopping the dead – they shoulda flew
out and burned the dead before they even arrived.
Maybe Dany and Jon are worried about the Night
King’s Olympic javelin skills.
But that means relying on footsoldiers to
hold off an endless zombie horde long enough
to kill the Night King – assuming the Night
King even shows up.
So like the wight hunt last season, this plan
is pretty ridiculous – it’s almost like
this is a TV show and it’s meant to be dramatic.
The interesting bit is when Bran explains
the motivation of the white walkers.
He says the Night King wants to “erase this
world” and bring “An endless night”.
He specifically wants to kill Bran because
as the three-eyed raven, Bran is the world’s
memory – in the books, the magic of the
weirwoods stores the souls of the dead, and
remembers the history of the earth Sam says
that memory is what makes us human, and forgetting
is death . Thrones author George Martin is
a melancholy romantic . He’s been writing
for decades about ghosts and songs and lost
loves – all different echoes of the past.
And that shines through in Game of Thrones.
The story is about vengeance and grief and
loyalty and guilt, all feelings that are rooted
in memories of loss and love.
That's why the north remembers, why the Starks
treasure their crypts, why Ned Stark and Rhaegar
are still important characters even though
they’re long dead.
Memory makes us human, so it makes sense that
the ultimate evil in this story is a metaphor
for forgetting our humanity.
That said, it's all very fucken abstract.
Shouldn't the big bad guys have a more specific
motivation?
There are all these weird hints of baby sacrifice,
spooky spirals, ancient mystery.
The books hint at ancient pacts, and secret
bloodlines, there’s Coldhands, and Joramun’s
Horn, the Five Forts, and Bloodstone Emperor
– surely that adds up to something more
than this metaphor.
There may still be secrets to reveal about
the walkers – whether in this show, or the
prequel show, or in upcoming books.
Tyrion speaks with Bran.
It is crazy that Bran is apparently an omniscient
psychic know-it-all, yet no one asks him what
he knows, or what his powers are.
Tyrion, at least, sees the value in knowledge,
so he asks to hear Bran’s story , but the
scene cuts before we hear anything.
So what did Tyrion learn?
On the excellent Still Watching podcast, the
writer of this episode, Bryan Cogman, suggested
that Tyrion and Bran just talked about Bran’s
journey, nothing super important happened
. But Tyrion does seem more optimistic about
the battle after speaking with Bran . Maybe
Bran told him something that’ll help in
the fight.
Missandei says hi to some northern girls,
and they run off.
She’s treated as an unwelcome foreigner
here, and Grey Worm says they should go somewhere
else after the war.
Missandei wants to go back to Naath , her
homeland, where she lived before she was enslaved.
The Naathi are called the Peaceful People
– they don’t eat meat, and don’t kill
people, even in self-defence.
So they’re often attacked by slavers or
conquerors, but their enemies don’t last
long.
Because Naath is full of butterflies that
carry a disease that kills outsiders.
Of course that would mean they’d kill Grey
Worm, so maybe this is only true in the books.
Point is, this is a touching moment of two
lovers dreaming of a happily ever after.
So it’s the perfect setup for some heart-wrenching
tragedy next episode – maybe Grey Worm or
Missandei will die.
Sam Edd and Jon talk on the walls of Winterfell.
We finally see Jon’s direwolf Ghost – though
he’s still much smaller than in the books.
The book-direwolves get huge , and have deep
symbolic and magic connections with each Stark.
Jon Sam and Edd were in the Night’s Watch
together.
Along with Grenn and Pyp and the rest, they
survived wildlings and wights and worse, but
now it’s just these three left . Sam and
Jon laugh at Edd for being a virgin, which
is a bit rich.
The Night’s Watch oaths are understood to
mean having no sex – Jon and Sam broke that
rule.
But the rules are out the window [like Bran]
now anyway, cause the Wall has fallen, and
the Night’s Watch all but dissolved.
Still, Jon Sam and Edd keep the important
bits of their oath – they are the swords
in the darkness, the watchers on the walls,
the shield that guards the realms of men . The
Night’s Watch was founded thousand years
ago to defend the living from the dead.
And tonight, everyone at Winterfell is Night’s
Watch . Tyrion and Jaime reflect on how far
they’ve come.
Last time they were here, Jaime was proud
golden lion, and Tyrion a drunken whoremonger.
Now Jaime has lost his pride and his hand,
and Tyrion has lost his taste for prostitutes
– this is partly tied to his grief for Shae,
and Tyrion also mentions “self-betterment”
– he’s more focussed now on making a difference
in the world.
Tyrion mentions how mad their father would
be if he knew his sons were fighting for the
Starks.
Tywin was brutal in his war to destroy the
Starks and make House Lannister a dynasty
to last a thousand years.
But now, House Lannister’s all but gone,
and it’s the Stark legacy that lives on.
Game of Thrones is a dark story where good
guys die, but the message isn’t totally
bleak.
Acts of heroism and love outshine the darkness,
so long as they’re remembered.
Brienne, Pod, Tormund and Davos join the Lannisters.
Tormund tells a ridiculous story about suckling
on a giant.
He’s got heaps of that stuff in the books
– he claims that a bear bit off half his
penis, but that his penis is still twice as
large as anyone else’s . So these unlikely
companions share warmth and wine, in the face
of probable death tomorrow.
Meanwhile, the Hound sits alone in the cold
– until Arya comes along.
In Season 4, Arya and the Hound were kindred
spirits.
They both use violence and hate to hide their
loneliness and fear.
But after they parted ways, the Hound’s
become all heroic, fighting for the good guys,
when he used to only care for himself.
Arya asks why he changed, and the Hound replies
that he fought for Arya . It seems that their
bond taught the Hound that it’s worth fighting
to protect others.
Beric Dondarrion shows up – he used to be
on Arya’s death list for selling Gendry
to Melisandre, but Arya’s let go of that.
Beric talks about his god, the Lord of Light,
and says “This is his moment” . The Lord
of Light is all about good versus evil, light
versus dark, all that Zoroastrian stuff.
Next episode’s battle for the dawn might
be Beric’s time to fulfil his destiny in
some fiery sacrifice.
In the books, Beric gives up his life force
to resurrect Catelyn.
So maybe Beric will resurrect someone next
episode.
Tormund is shocked to learn that Brienne isn’t
a knight.
Because in Westeros, women aren’t allowed
to be knights.
Part of the point of Brienne’s character
is to show how unjust this sexist system is.
Brienne is more brave and selfless and honourable
than most any actual knight , yet this her
society denies her knighthood because of her
gender.
Tormund calls bullshit on that, and Jaime
makes Brienne a knight.
This is the ultimate vindication for Brienne
– the acknowledgement and respect that she’s
always deserved.
It’s also important for Jaime – in many
ways, he was a failed knight, an oathbreaker,
who hurt innocent people.
Now, he raises up a true knight.
This is an intimate moment for Brienne and
Jaime – the scene almost feels like a wedding.
Jaime declares his faith in Brienne, just
as she did for him before.
Jaime and Brienne might never kiss or have
sex, but this knighting is a moment of love.
Sam gives Jorah the Valyrian sword Heartsbane.
This was the sword of Sam’s father Randyll.
But Randyll was an asshole, and Sam took the
sword to represent his rejection of his father.
Instead, Sam says that Jeor Mormont was a
father to him.
Jeor was Commander of the Night’s Watch,
and was Jorah’s father.
Jorah failed his father by slaving and leaving
Westeros.
But now Sam gives Jorah Heartsbane “to guard
the realms of men” , as Jeor would have
wanted.
So this is another example of a character
whose memory long outlives his death.
But it’s also the story of a man who rejects
his biological father and chooses another
man as his father – which could be relevant
for Jon.
Jon is the biological son of Rhaegar, but
Ned Stark is his father.
Podrick sings a song about love and loss and
memory.
It’s about the ghosts of the friends and
family that these characters have lost, and
the ghosts of the people they used to be.
It’s a moment of bittersweet melancholy,
as they share one last night of love and light
in the face of death and forgetting – a
dream of spring as winter comes . The song
also ties deeply into the lore.
The song is called Jenny’s song, named for
Jenny of Oldstones, a mysterious woman who
lived fifty years ago.
She dwelt among ruins, danced with ghosts,
and wore flowers in her hair.
Prince Duncan Targaryen fell in love with
her, and gave up his crown to marry her . Jenny
had a friend who was a witch, and claimed
to be a child of the forest.
This witch is still alive in the books, as
the ghost of High Heart, and she makes a bunch
of accurate prophecies.
Back in the day, she prophesied that the prince
that was promised – the hero who’ll save
the world – will be born of the line of
the Mad King Aerys and his sister.
So, they got married, and had Rhaegar Viserys
and Daenerys.
Rhaegar was born at the tragic fire of Summerhall,
which killed Prince Duncan, and possibly Jenny.
Rhaegar spent his emo teenage years in the
ruins of Summerhall, singing sad songs.
Some fans speculate that Rhaegar may have
written Jenny’s song.
This may be the song that Rhaegar played to
woo Lyanna Stark – leading to the birth
of their child Jon.
So Jenny’s song is a thread of prophecy
and melancholy that runs from Jon and Dany
back through Rhaegar and Summerhall to Jenny.
And now, Jon reveals to Daenerys that Rhaegar
is his father.
This means that Daenerys is Jon’s aunt,
and Jon has a better claim to the Throne than
she does.
Daenerys has fought for the Throne for seven
seasons, so she’s deeply shaken by Jon’s
claim.
Of course, Jon doesn’t want the Throne,
which could tie back to Jenny’s song.
Prince Duncan gave up his crown out of love
for Jenny.
Maybe Jon will give up his crown for Daenerys.
Or maybe Daenerys will give up hers – remember
Sam asked last episode if Daenerys would give
up her crown . Alternatively, Jon and Dany
could get married and rule together.
But such a happy ending seems unlikely – the
white walkers arrive at Winterfell.
Jenny’s song, and kind of this whole episode
is about characters haunted by the dead, by
the metaphorical ghosts of the past.
But they’re also haunted by a very literal
army of the dead.
The zombies are here, and they’re led by
a lot of white walkers.
Remember, wights are the zombies, and they’re
pretty easy to kill.
But white walkers are the ice people who lead
the dead, and we’ve only seen a few of them.
Now there a dozens or hundreds of walkers
at Winterfell – where did they all come
from?
We know that Craster gave his babies to be
transformed into white walkers, and he was
probably not the only person doing this – there
are wildlings in the far north rumoured to
worship cold gods.
So over thousand of years, the walkers must
have slowly built up these numbers.
The walkers also have zombie giants, and animals
like polar bears.
There are legends about giant ice spiders.
And the white walkers are led by the Night
King, riding the dragon Viserion – but we
don’t see them here.
Some fans speculate that the Night King won’t
join this battle, and instead, he’ll fly
south and attack King’s Landing, turning
its million inhabitants into another army
of the dead.
This would be similar to the Battle of the
Whispering Wood, when Robb Stark split his
army, and surprise attacked Jaime – Jaime
mentions the Whispering Wood this episode
. The excellent History of Westeros podcast
points out another possible parallel in Thrones
history.
In the Dance of the Dragons, Aemond Targaryen,
a dragon-rider with a blue sapphire eye , split
from his army and attacked elsewhere.
So Daemon Targaryen and his lover Nettles
chased him down, on their dragons.
Maybe, similarly, Jon and Daenerys will have
to chase down the Night King.
But that’s just a guess – we’ll find
out soon.
This is the second episode of six episode
season, and not very much has happened.
Some fans dismiss this as pointless farnarkling.
But the point of these episodes is to remind
us why we care about these characters – before
the next episodes rip them away.
This is Jenny’s song, remembering the ghosts
that give these characters humanity, in the
face of darkness and death.
When Brienne is knighted, Tyrion calls her
a “Knight of the Seven Kingdoms”.
That’s the title of a collection of Game
of Thrones prequel stories about a knight
called Duncan the Tall.
George Martin has hinted that Dunk is an ancestor
of Brienne – they’re similar characters.
Like Brienne, Dunk is an underdog.
He’s not the smartest or the strongest,
and it’s implied he’s not really a knight.
But he’s brave and honourable, and he upholds
his vows – here’s a quote from the audiobook:
“He charged me to be a good knight and true,
to obey the seven gods, defend the weak and
innocent, serve my lord faithfully, and defend
the realm with all my might, and I swore that
I would”.
In A Knight of the Seven Kingdoms, Dunk adventures
across Westeros with a Targaryen kid.
He meets a young three-eyed raven and a young
Walder Frey, and he kisses the woman who becomes
Jaime Lannister’s great-grandmother.
You can read all of Dunk’s stories for free
today by signing up for a trial with Audible.
Members get a book each month, and if you
cancel, you keep the books.
You can read in the car or the gym or while
drinking and waiting for the apocalypse.
Sign up at audible.com/asx.
Thanks for watching, and thanks to the artists
for their work.
Thanks to the Patrons, including Bloody Tyrant,
Scarlett, Random Vowels, Gina, and Sam Lundin
of House Vimbly, first of his name, Lord of
Union Square, and Protector of the Realm.
Cheers.